-Republicans are making clear
that they have no interest
in hearing the truth
about Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
As the President faced
a growing crisis
over the sexual-assault
allegations
against his
Supreme Court nominee,
he flew to North Carolina
to survey damage
from Hurricane Florence.
And as usual,
he was super weird about it.
At one point,
according to reporters...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God, I swear Trump could
see a guy jump off a building
and think,
"Oh, cool -- free shoes."
[ Laughter ]
And in case you think
Trump was just kidding,
he later told reporters...
[ Laughter ]
Ah, yes.
Who could forget
the famous Supreme Court case
of Finders v. Keepers.
[ Laughter ]
This is the guy...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That right there is the guy
who gets to pick
our next Supreme Court Justice,
a man who thinks that,
legally speaking,
if a boat shows up on your lawn,
you get to keep it.
[ Laughter ]
And yet it's very much the case
that Republicans are hoping
Trump will be able
to reshape the Supreme Court
for a generation by rushing to
get his nominee Brett Kavanaugh
confirmed despite the credible
sexual-assault allegations
against him.
Republicans have been engaged
in a 40-year project
to install a conservative
majority on the court,
and Kavanaugh's nomination
was supposed to be
the crowning achievement
in that project.
And Trump was very proud
of his choice,
although he mainly
seemed concerned
with whether Kavanaugh
looked the part.
-Hopefully, everything goes
very well with Judge Kavanaugh.
He's central casting.
You know, 10 years ago,
they said, "He'll be
a Supreme Court judge."
Justice Kavanaugh
is doing great.
Looks like --
I don't know, very tough.
Central casting.
-I don't know.
If he really
came from central casting,
they wouldn't make him
a Supreme Court Justice.
They'd make him
the manager on "Superstore."
[ Laughter ]
And if you think Kavanaugh
would never lie,
here he is in his first remarks
as a Supreme Court nominee
in order to shamelessly
suck up to Trump.
-Mr. President, thank you.
Throughout this process,
I've witnessed firsthand
your appreciation for the vital
role of the American judiciary.
No president
has ever consulted more widely
or talked with more people
for from more backgrounds
to seek input about
a Supreme Court nomination.
-There is absolutely no way
that is true.
[ Laughter ]
He might as well have said,
"No president has ever
looked better in a white Polo."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But Kavanaugh --
Kavanaugh was willing to lie
to please his boss because he's
been a loyal partisan Republican
for most of his career,
someone conservatives know
they'll be able to depend on
to implement their agenda.
Trump himself even claimed he'd
heard Kavanaugh's name mentioned
as a possible Supreme Court
Justice for years.
-He's an outstanding intellect.
He's an outstanding judge.
He was born for the position.
I heard as long as 10 years ago
people were saying
he should be
a Supreme Court judge.
I didn't know him at the time,
but I was hearing
from a lot of people,
friends of mine from Washington
and other places,
saying that Brett Kavanaugh
should be
a Supreme Court judge someday.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
You did not hear people saying
Brett Kavanaugh
should be a Supreme Court
Justice 10 years ago.
10 years ago,
you were yelling at Gary Busey
for stealing
Meat Loaf's art supplies.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Kavanaugh's nomination
was the culmination
of a decades-long ideological
project to reshape the Court,
and Republicans
are making it clear
that they want to see
that project through,
even if it means
ignoring a credible allegation
of sexual assault.
Trump was asked
about the allegations
against Kavanaugh made
by Dr. Christine Blasey Ford.
Trump said he wanted
the process to play out
while making clear
he was firmly behind Kavanaugh.
-We are looking to get this done
as quickly as possible.
He is a truly
outstanding person, as you know.
He is an incredible man.
He's an incredible intellect.
He will make an incredible
Supreme Court Justice,
but we feel that we want
to go through a process.
We want to hear both sides.
He can handle himself
better than anybody.
He's a very outstanding man.
Thank you.
-Oh, I'm totally supportive.
Yes, I'm very supportive.
-You can't say you want
a fair and open process
but also that
you're supportive of one side.
He's like a ref
at the Super Bowl saying,
"Let's have a good, clean game
so we can get that handsome
Tom Brady another trophy."
[ Laughter ]
The White House is trying
to have it both ways.
They're trying to insulate Trump
from the political fallout
if Kavanaugh's nomination
blows up
while also standing firmly
behind their
Supreme Court nominee.
In fact, on Monday,
Kavanaugh was at the White House
for nine hours of meetings,
but White House staff made sure
to keep Trump away from him.
-Inside the White House,
they were hunkered down,
closely monitoring everything,
but keeping the judge away from
meeting with President Trump,
who was nearby
in the Oval Office,
meeting with officials, as well.
-Why?
-They don't meet, Chris,
based on my reporting,
because they want
to protect the President.
-So, Kavanaugh
was in the building all day,
and they had to keep Trump
away from him.
That means that, for nine hours,
it was someone's job
inside the White House
to keep Trump distracted.
"Okay, guys,
gonna be a long day.
Get me three remote controls,
an issue of "Juggs" magazine,
and a cheeseburger on a string.
[ Laughter ]
"Damn you, cheeseburger."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The cheeseburger
won't stand still."
[ Applause ]
The Republicans' gambit here
is to make it seem like
they want a fair
and open process,
but in reality, they want it
to look like a he said, she said
so they can just ignore it
and move on.
They won't even
interview witnesses
or let the FBI investigate.
They made it clear
that they either
don't believe Ford's story
or don't care.
In fact, GOP Senators
are already insisting
that Ford must have
gotten her story wrong
or that she might be doing this
for political purposes.
-If Ms. Ford really did not
want to come forward,
never intended to come forward,
never planned to come forward,
why did she pay
for a polygraph in August,
and why did she
hire a lawyer in August
if she never intended
to do what she's doing?
-Senator Cornyn
this morning saying that
there are gaps in her story,
appear to be gaps in her story.
-Do you think that this,
in any way,
is going
to derail his nomination?
-No. He's a straight-shooting,
honest guy.
I think when people
listen to him, they'll know --
they'll know
that he's all right.
-And do you think that any of
these claims are legitimate?
-No, I don't.
I think --
I think this woman,
whoever she is, is mixed up.
-I love these old-ass Senators
claiming other people
are mixed up.
Just to give you
some perspective,
here's that same Senator,
Orrin Hatch,
asking Mark Zuckerberg
a question about Facebook
at a hearing earlier this year.
-How do you sustain
a business model
in which users
don't pay for your service?
[ Laughter ]
-Senator, we run ads.
-I see.
[ Laughter ]
-"Okay, okay.
But how do you get all the faces
inside the book?"
[ Laughter ]
"And where do you
print this book?
Can I get the book
at Barnes & Noble?
How many pages is the book?"
[ Laughter ]
"How much does the book cost?
Is the book available on Kindle?
And a follow-up question --
what's a Kindle?"
[ Laughter ]
Republicans are making it
as clear as possible
they don't actually
have an interest
in hearing the truth
of what happened.
They're rushing to get a man
accused of sexual assault
on the Supreme Court
because it's the culmination
of a 40-year project to solidify
their conservative majority
for a generation.
If you're looking for villains,
these guys
are straight out of...
-Central casting.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]